and now for technical difficulties with
Clint Howard sponsored by mug Club
camera Jasmine are you seeing anything
you're not supposed to
unfortunately no oh yeah well you know
guys I think fortunately you know is
probably the more appropriate answer
hang on give me a second I've got this
tripod there we go I'm sure you do I
just know it's actually just a long I do
I'm doing great Natalie I I there's a
lot of wonderful things going on and I'm
getting to do a really great scene with
my dad in a movie called Appleseed which
is gonna be I'm gonna shoot it next week
after Mayberry Days Inn in Mount Airy
North Carolina so hang on a second I'm
almost I'm almost giving you an angle
here hang on I'm just you know this is
an it this would be an $800
this would be an $800 grip gap if I
frigging um this is teetering on the
edge of Apple disaster here and hold on
I had it I had it you guys make me
nervous
oh don't be nervous no weird well I'm
getting ready to go to Mayberry days I'm
Barney 5:00 so you know wouldn't Barney
be nervous he would be there in
assessors Oh what did God anytime you
see dawn do any of that acting he's
absolutely brilliant when you go back
and look at clips of Don Knotts doing
comedy oh yeah there's no there was
nobody better ever one of my favorite
movies was him in a Tim Conway privatise
yeah love it I grew up on that as broad
as as broad as Don was he
[Laughter]
are you good are you seeing me we do it
you sound kind of muffled ow did you see
well hold on we might need it just
happened hang on now how is the sound
guy seriously
it's cut it's coming back I think we're
getting there yeah you know that's
amazing what a little rifle boy wouldn't
I'd be great if we could do that if we
could get that it would be good now are
you seeing me
no it's frozen right now I think it's uh
maybe maybe like you're not in the app
oh wait like you want to try back real
quick let's do that okay call me right
back cuz I'm all set now all right
[Music]
recording all of that calling
there mr. Howard
how are you is that booting up um it
seems to you yeah I think we're almost
there okay hang on guys now what are you
guys getting ready to be way late right
no we're gonna be a couple extra minutes
here okay how's that that's perfect
right now because I'm outdoors I can't
see you at all Stephen so you can't even
indicate to me lean left lean right I'm
gonna stay right in the middle and look
right there that's perfect okay again
all right thank you so much I was I was
I was not at your I was laughing my ass
off when I thought we thought we lost
you cuz all we see is the phone go in
the water it just says connection law if
we reimburse you but we don't I think
you're covering your mic now with your
finger maybe better without the
headphones I wonder yeah let's try
without the headphones and maybe because
if you're outside it might not have an
echo wait for it to clear up for a
second you can't he can't hear us if he
takes off his headphones
[Music]
noise-cancelling it's got the rubber
I can hear you yeah I can hold on I can
it's almost like he's covering with his
hand
yeah that's not saying I'm something
he's covering with his hand well no cuz
I cuz I need took it out of the water
madam it keeps going in and out okay so
I leave you here
no no no oh now we can hear you really
but we can't see here Oh things the
links ago do you hear me
I can hear you but I can't see you now
tell us that's paused
maybe you paused accidentally see that's
the problem
glasses would help because blind people
don't have very much luck doing this I'm
typing in my super secret NBA password
and I am back on the air now yet I think
you bet need click on the app we can't
see I think you need to clean is it like
a green bar at the top of your screen or
maybe it's red I think it's green that
should go back into the app the FaceTime
app
how's that now you're calling him back
yeah let's try call you back coming back
I'm also too hot in this I'm I just need
to take out the undershirt and deal with
the wallet now yes there you go yeah we
can we can hear you we can see you it's
a little muffle with the sound but we'll
take it no wait wait there we go that's
fine now he can hear you fine drop it in
the water again now yeah
alright let's just let's just go let's
go that's negative dear just go just go
[Music]
no social media to plug this has been
technical difficulties with Clint Howard
sponsored by bug Club hey did you enjoy
this video here's your thing you wrote
your this is the end of it so we don't
care cuz you already watched it but if
you really didn't like it and you want
to justify it leave a comment below
telling us why you didn't like the video
and if you liked us let us know and
subscribe to the channel because that
lets the overlords at YouTube know that
you know what you're alright